estoy pensando en obtener un seguro de
vida pues tengo una hipoteca un hijo
pequeño y otro bebé que viene en camino
por lo que si algo me pasara me gustaría
que ellos al menos tengan para poder
pagar la hipoteca y que tal vez les
quede algo de dinero para la escuela o
para vivir o lo que sea así que fui a
una compañía aseguradora y quise obtener
una póliza por un millón de pesos y como
sabes se puede contratar temporalmente
por lo que a mí me interesa por los
próximos 20 años pues esperando que
después de estos 20 años yo pueda saldar
mi hipoteca y que pueda ahorrar mi
dinero y quizás mis hijos tengan una
especie de ahorro para sus escuelas en
lugar de guardarlo y es por eso que esta
póliza tiene un tiempo de vida o
temporalidad u otra opción de esto es
una póliza de vida entera donde
podríamos pagar una cierta cantidad por
un año o por el resto de tu vida tal que
en cualquier momento que tú mueras
obtienes
de pesos por lo que hasta el término de
mi vida voy a pagar 500 pesos por año
al año y en la primera opción era por 20
años y en cualquier momento de estos 20
años yo muriera mi familia tendría el
millón de pesos y al término de estos 20
años yo tendría que obtener una nueva
póliza en la cual yo ya sería más vieja
y ya tendría más probabilidad de morir
en ese momento por lo que seguramente
sería más caro para mí obtener un seguro
en ese momento así que lo que estoy
haciendo aquí es poner la probabilidad
de que yo muera en 20 años pues en
realidad lo que les importa a estas
compañías aseguradoras es cuál es la
probabilidad de que mueran en estos
próximos 20 años pues la máxima
probabilidad de que yo muera es la forma
en que ellos pueden hacer o ganar dinero
así que vamos a multiplicar 500 pesos
que pagó por 20 años lo cual es igual a
10.000 y lo vamos a dividir
entre la suma asegurada que es el millón
de pesos están haciendo un cociente de
lo que están pagando entre la suma
asegurada al final al cancelar estos
ceros nos queda un peso que está siendo
para nuestra prima asegurada y nos queda
abajo simplemente 100 del seguro de vida
que es lo que nos estaríamos ofreciendo
entonces tenemos un peso en primas por
cada 100 pesos en el seguro y otra forma
de pensar esto es decir ok vamos a
pensar que tenemos 100 asegurados en 100
personas observadas durante 20 años que
es el tiempo de vida del seguro entonces
son 100 personas como yo 100 personas
que están siendo aseguradas entonces son
100 pesos en primas pues serán un peso
para una persona serían 100 pesos para
100 personas como yo que se están
asegurando
y ahora son 100 personas de las que
obtuvieron 100 pesos en primas y la
única forma en que ellos podrían ganar
dinero esta única forma en como ellos
ganarían o más bien que tuvieran un
punto de equilibrio sería que como
máximo sólo una persona muriera sólo una
de estas personas muriera por lo que
este será un punto de equilibrio y esto
es solo si una persona muere en realidad
esto es un poco fuerte de platicar
porque estamos hablando de la muerte de
una persona por lo que la única forma
para que este punto de equilibrio pase
es que la probabilidad de que las
personas como yo aseguradas mueran en
los próximos 20 años sea menor o igual a
un centésimo pues dicha compañía
aseguradora está tratando de ganar
dinero entonces probablemente haya
muchas más de estas personas son mucho
más números porque yo estoy siendo
optimista pensando que la probabilidad
en que yo muera sea un centésimo lo cual
me hace sentir mejor puesto que es una
probabilidad baja pero puede que haya
probabilidades más altas de que más
personas
la compañía no le convenga por eso es
que yo digo que más sentir mejor puesto
que es probable que yo no muera